[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARILIA MELO: Hi, everybody.
My name is Marilia Melo.
I'll be hosting this Fireside
Chat with Melissa and Andrew.
And to start, I actually want to
ask you all who are here today,
how many of you do already have
an SRE team in your company?
Please raise your hand.
[LAUGHTER]
MELISSA BINDE: I see all the
Googlers raising their hands.
Stop that!
MARILIA MELO: And
how many of you
are actually thinking about
starting a new SRE team
or hiring for your own,
already existing SRE team?
OK.
Cool.
So we'll be talking here today
about how to start an SRE
and also how to hire
SREs and other questions.
This is open to questions
from you as well.
I do have a few questions
that I will be starting with.
But we will have time for you
to make questions as well.
So please start
thinking about that.
If I don't cover the questions
here, please raise your hand.
And you're going to give
you the mic as well.
So the first question
I have on here--
it is probably a
challenging one--
is how do I know when my
org needs an SRE team?
So what justifies
for me an SRE team?
What issues exist?
And what are the
potential benefits?
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: Want to start?
MELISSA BINDE: Sure.
So the question is, how do I
know when I need an SRE team?
Andrew and I decided
ahead of time,
I would take the big company and
he would take the small company
perspective, so you'll get both.
From a big company
perspective, what
we're looking at is, if
you have an SRE team,
how do you know when to
make an additional SRE team
or shard off to a new org?
And there's two
things we look at.
You're looking for technology
and focus that is similar.
So I was involved in
the creation of GCP SRE.
And we split it off from our
internal tech infra-SRE teams.
And we did that because we
saw that there was actually
a critical difference
between interacting
with external customers
and the concerns
that external customers had
about how we handle their SLOs,
how we handled our responses,
that differed from how
we did internal software.
And trying to combine
the two in one focus just
wasn't actually giving us the
amount of leadership bandwidth
that we needed.
So splitting that off helped us
service you folks much better
and allowed our
internal team to really
be able to focus
on what they cared
most about, which was the
capacity, the efficiency focus.
The other thing to do is to
look at your dev partners.
You want to have an
organization generally
that aligns at least
somewhat with them.
And when you have one focus
covering a large dev swath,
they may not be getting
the kind of partnership
they're looking for.
So that was the
other thing that we
did, was we were
able to then split up
our dev VPs across
the two of us and get
better coordination
with the dev teams,
better depth of
knowledge, and better
alignment with the business.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: So I'm going
to take more of the historical,
like how would you
seed your first SRE
team from Google's basis.
A show of hands here-- how
many people have gone from
and are currently at from 0
to 1 SRE teams, or just about
to go to their first?
In Google's history, SRE was
formed because there was--
out of all of the broad, general
software engineering worlds,
there were several people
who had self-identified
and clustered around
the production boundary,
the production interface.
They were literally
called "production team."
And it was interesting because
it wasn't the production ops
team or what have you.
It was the software engineers
most production-curious,
as it were.
And I think it was
a very important
and, I think, accidentally,
insightful thing that Google
did which was, they said
we recognize this boundary
and we want to support it.
So take a look around.
Humans are curious creatures.
And they'll tend to just do what
they want to do, within reason.
See if you can
encourage and seed--
may I suggest-- an SRE team
from the general, traditional
engineering side with those
most production-adjacent,
in order to keep that
engineering aspect
from day one.
MELISSA BINDE: I
often describe it
as, you're looking for the
folks who are more interested
in the activities
around the software
than in chewing out
lines of code themselves.
And I suspect this applies
to a bunch of folks
here because you're all here.
But the people who get
really annoyed when
you have a bunch of bugs
that are out of date,
or your CI/CD pipeline
isn't working right,
or your pushes keep stalling.
And it's not that you
don't like writing code
but you keep being
attracted to solve
those problems
around the software,
not just in the software.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: So maybe
an indicative sign of this
is, like we were saying,
is if you are here,
how many of your colleagues at
any level of your organization
would also like to
be here right now?
Is it more than two?
You probably have a nascent
SRE team already happening.
You should just fund it.
MARILIA MELO: Awesome.
I think we started
to talk a little bit
about the next question as well.
So we have two or three people--
n plus 2-- people that
want to do this SRE thing.
So we have an SRE team.
It's a buzz word
recently, right?
SRE, SRE.
So we created an SRE team.
But we're not really sure
what it should be doing.
So in reality, what
is the SRE team doing?
And we can either split and
start out versus big as well.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: OK, so
side-note-- forgive me
if I'm all
hyperbole-laden and come
to Candy Mountain about this.
I spend a lot of my time doing
college and industry recruiting
for SREs to come to Google.
So naturally I'm biased
and excited about this.
But the way I try to
explain the role of an SRE
is, it's really--
whether or not you buy into the
whole left-brain, right-brain
thing.
I'm going to instead say,
two halves of the brain
are proactive and
reactive, right?
Yes, of course, there's
the carry-the-pager,
the react-to-various-things,
the vigilance and the diligence
type stuff.
This is all well and good.
But there's also this very
much a always-be-prepared,
within reason, within
proportionate reason sort
of way.
What I mean is, having
the regular conversations
in your team, the
disaster drills,
the let's think about
the best and worst
that can happen type stuff.
So it's an equal balance.
You want to be there at the
earliest part of the design
phase, in order to be able to
make the subtle improvements
from the experience
and the gravitas
that you and SRE
has had for years
from doing this sort of thing,
to influence and make sure
that the arrow bars on a
launch of something that
has been designed x months
ago aren't very large.
The biggest non-event
of the summer
should be the launch of
said product or project
that you were involved in.
So I'm looking for folks who
are good engineers, but also
good reverse engineers,
which is something sometimes
we forget to think about.
I'm not necessarily saying it
should be a bunch of IT jockeys
who question authority
and always look
to break the alarm clocks open
to figure out how they work,
or any variant of that.
What I'm thinking about is
people who are inquisitive,
people who are
analytical, people
who want to understand
a whole system.
And that can come from either
software engineering, and/or IT
and ops.
It's a spectrum.
These are the sorts of things
I look for in the fellow folks
that I bring into
an SRE organization.
MELISSA BINDE: And I
want to expand on that.
It is dangerously
easy to develop
a monoculture in
your SRE team based
on the values of the person
who is most influential,
which might be the start or the
first manager or the leader,
whatever.
If that person is highly
biased towards, very often,
reactive stuff, you
can get an SRE team
that is going to
double down way too
much on being excited by
incidents and way too little
on long-term planning.
If the person
happens to actually
be like a frustrated
software engineer who'd
be rather writing
code that got told
they're not good
enough so they have
to be an SRE-- by the
way, that's terrible.
Don't do that.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: Horrible.
MELISSA BINDE: But
you're going to get
a team that is
constantly railing
against wanting to do
features on the product
instead of doing
automation code.
So a really critical thing
is to think through all the
different--
SRE is an incredibly
multidisciplinary activity.
You need people who are good
at deep software debugging.
at understanding distributed
systems.
You need people who are
good at understanding
the ways your
infrastructure can go wrong.
There's so many
different aspects of it.
Because then you've
got the immediate
versus the long-term, the
break fix, the designs.
You want as diverse
intellectually a crew
as you can.
If you're interviewing someone
who is completely unlike you
but interested in it,
that's a really good sign.
And focusing on that
when building your team,
drawing from as
diverse a background,
and diverse in every
possible way that you can,
you will build a much
stronger team at the end.
Because everyone can learn
how to answer a pager.
But having people who are
interested in the long term,
people who are interested
in the short term.
We have some SREs who their
most exciting moment is
when we declare a
Google-wide incident,
and they get to be at the
command of the helm of getting
a whole bunch of people
to respond to something.
I've watched those folks.
I'm not those people.
My interest is really
on the product side.
And how do I make customers
as happy as we possibly can?
And then I have
some colleagues who
are so deep into the hardware
and the optimizations
and what performance
can we eke out of this.
But all of us together
are what make SRE great.
Any one over-indexed would
not produce a good team.
MARILIA MELO: In this
respect, how do we
actually prioritize
the activities
that the SRE should be doing?
For example, should we be
focusing on emergency response?
Should we be focusing on the
dashboards, the monitoring?
How is that conversation like
to focus on the activities
that they would be doing?
ANDREW WIDDOWSON:
I think it really
depends on the size and
the trajectory of the team.
Because a very well tenured,
fully fleshed out team,
I think, will have a different
resting set of ratios.
And also I don't think that
every single person on the SRE
team will have the exact
same set of interests.
So you afford the
luxury of being
able to kind of load-balance
from within, once
you get to a series of stable
engagements, a relatively
well-known space, but
still a lot of change
in the velocity of the
individual products.
When you start--
and, by the way,
I have my own set of opinions
on the minimum spanning
set of SREs.
Best SRE [INAUDIBLE]
that I've ever seen
is we're going to
hire one person.
We're going to
work all the SWEs.
That's called a scapegoat
reliability engineer.
And that's how you
do your SRE work.
We can go more into
what not to do later.
But essentially, let's say you
have a minimum set of people
who are all very
new to the role, who
are trying to get up to speed.
There's a lot of running to get
in front of the treadmill slash
people mover that may happen.
But it's how you do it, I
think, that's most important,
that will afford you the
ability to get to a point
like I mentioned previously.
MARILIA MELO: Do
you want to add--
how do you prioritize
the activities
the SRE team will be doing?
MELISSA BINDE: I don't have
much to add to what Andrew said,
other than to answer a slightly
different aspect of it,
which is that I would simply
encourage you to make sure you
are actually prioritizing.
Because it's very
easy to not prioritize
and to have the urgent
always trump the important.
One of the ways I like to
talk about this is in terms
of budgets, where you say, OK,
we are planning on having 20%
of our team's energy going
towards working with the devs
on new products, 50% of our
team's energy going towards
doing automation on the stuff
we've already on-boarded
and-- math--
30% of our team's energy going
towards operational issues.
And then actually
test that that's true.
And when it's not,
stop and think--
is this really actually
the thing to do or are you
just reacting?
I have SRE teams tell me they
can't possibly tell their devs
that they cannot spend only 20%
of their time on new products.
I'm like, well, have you tried?
Because it actually turns out
to work surprisingly well.
People understand the
concept of budgets.
They understand I have
a lot of things to do
and this is how I'm
prioritizing things.
So that's one of my favorite
ways to handle is with budgets.
MARILIA MELO: Nice.
And you talk a
little bit about what
I'm going to ask next again.
Thank you.
So how should the SRE teams
view their relationships
with the developers
in the company?
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: I
think it's a matter
of mutual respect at all times.
So for example, here's a
couple of anti-patterns.
I'm going to come in,
and you've got velocity
and you've got reliability.
And they're 180 degrees out of
phase with each other, right?
Wrong.
But OK.
So what's the best way to
increase our stability?
Fire all the humans.
Stop making changes.
Right?
Like, that is the best way
to quickly reduce yourselves
to the exaggeration of a
strictly only ops organization.
MELISSA BINDE: It's amazing
how stable your system
is over the winter holidays.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: Yeah, exactly.
Let's just freeze all the time.
So the way I like to pitch the
value of SRE to any dev team
that I work with is, we want to
be there from day one with you.
We've got your back
and vice-versa.
I also want to explain, like the
way I talk with my hands a lot.
I try to make it
maximally orthogonal,
the relationship between
velocity and stability.
How many people here learned
to drive an automobile
in a car that had a driver's ed
person in the passenger seat?
And they had a brake.
If your dev organization
perceives you
as the driver ed
instructor with the brake,
you're doing it wrong.
If they perceive you as the
weird person riding shotgun
with you that has an
extra accelerator pedal,
you're probably
doing it way better.
I will often work
with my dev teams
to say, how can we go faster?
I'm going to write
the automation.
I'm going to write the
safe guardrails to make it
so that we can decouple some
of the scariness from this.
We'll make things auto-rollback.
We'll figure out ways
to do experiments.
We'll segment stuff.
One cherry-picked CR will
not tank the whole release.
We'll be able to march forward
and backward on our features,
promoting the most reliable
ones, those sorts of things.
So if you get into
a shouting match,
if you get into a postmortem--
I'm going to point
at someone I know
in the audience-- it's a blame
exercise-- they can take it.
That's bad.
It really should be, I've saved
your butt several times over.
And we've made this
faster together.
We've saved each other's butts.
I think that's really good.
If you start off from an
adversarial relationship,
there is no way, in my opinion--
from having looked at this time
and time again-- to somehow--
it's not like you can flip
like binary bit overflow,
and suddenly you're
back around to respect.
You have to start from,
we're here together.
And sometimes that
comes structurally,
like you were forged
from the same fire,
but from different VPs.
It's very rarely from,
someone screwed up
and now we're going
to replace them
with the people who are
mystical, and magical,
and misunderstood or the
people who are adversarial.
There's really a
set of fine balance.
And if you don't check in
all the time and communicate,
that will go off the
rails just automatically.
MELISSA BINDE: There's a
couple of failure modes
I've seen that SREs can
take deep offense to and not
realize that it's just the
devs not always thinking things
through.
Probably the prime one is--
just going off what you said--
the end is that SREs are
magical unicorns--
unicorns.
In terms of the
devs-- like I've had
a dev say this to me, that
they couldn't possibly
take on this project.
And I said, why not?
They said, well, we don't
know anything about the code.
I'm like, literally, what
do you do for a job, dude?
I mean, I'm sorry.
We take on code we
don't know all the time.
So can you.
It is easy for an
SRE team to fall
into kind of a blame
game and a pointing
there and say that
all the devs do
is throw stuff over the wall.
You have to sit
down and tell them
when that's happening and
say, hey, this isn't OK.
Can we talk about this?
Decently often, you're
having an SRE team
evolving out of an ops team.
And you have a lot of habits.
You have a lot of
things you're accepting.
And it can be very
dangerous for us
when we take a very adversarial
stance, as Andrew mentioned,
from day one, as opposed to
sitting down and working out
some new relationships, and
then having some agreements
that, hey, when things
go off the rails,
we're going to talk about it.
We're going to fix it.
I had one other thing
I was going to say.
What was it?
MARILIA MELO: I can
actually ask specifically
to your experience.
Because when you
started GCP SRE,
the devs were
already there, right?
You brought in the SREs.
Is there any specific
things that you
did to make sure that
the SREs and devs--
MELISSA BINDE: Yes.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
I'd change that very slightly,
which is that we actually
hired a lot of--
GCP has grown so
incredibly fast--
thank you all for buying it--
that we have hired a
large number of executives
from outside Google.
So in areas of Google that
have grown more slowly,
it's a very organic--
the VPs get beaten into
shape by their peers.
And they cooperate a
little bit more with SRE.
That is less true in GCP.
My job for a while was
literally educator of VPs.
And there was this class of
VPs that I taught all of them.
One of the key things
that we have, though,
in our toolbox at
Google that I think
isn't always common
outside, that
helps with this
adversarial relationship,
is the ability to politely
and calmly walk away,
the handing back of the pager.
And that's something that
I get people asking me.
Like I'll go into customer
meetings and the head of ops
will pull me aside
and go, no, really,
can you actually do that?
Like have you?
I've actually--
not me personally--
but I have had a
conversation with devs.
I've had one conversation where
I said, your service is bad.
And I am losing SREs.
And I'm not going to
block their transfer.
When this team gets too low,
we're going to have no choice.
Would you like to
change course now?
Spoiler-- they did.
And I've had other teams
where we've sat down
and we've had like
months-long conversation of,
is this a healthy relationship?
Is this something
we should continue?
And the thing is that
having that position to take
is both a relief valve
for SRE, because you
don't need to drive it to
the point of adversarialness.
But it's also a really good
sort of early warning discussion
with your devs.
But to have that you need a
culture where it's OK for devs
to be on call.
And that is a very hard
conversation in some companies.
Depending where you
come from, that's
either natural or
incredibly insane.
Feel free to tell them that
at Google all the devs, even
the ones with SREs,
are actually expected
to be able to be on call.
So we do.
We do do shared on-call.
Like most of my teams, the
devs will answer pagers
during the day.
And SRE takes them
overnight and after hours.
So, yeah, you can use my name.
Because often, well,
Google doesn't.
No, we do.
But you need those escape valves
because, at the end of the day,
as much as we want
to say partnership,
just like how QA tends to get
the short end of the stick
because they're the end
of the development cycle,
SRE can very easily get
the short end of the stick
if you have not
put in some rails
to help with the
power imbalance.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON:
May I underscore
this particular phenomenon.
And it is of course a
thought exercise to you
as to how this may or may not
apply at your own company.
At Google, let's just say
that there are about 60,000
engineer-shaped people.
There are 2,886--
as of yesterday--
SREs at the company.
So think about that ratio--
2 point mumble to 60.
So SRE are a scarce resource.
We're really hard to hire for.
That also means we go
where the action is.
And so, working backwards
from that, at Google,
most software engineers on most
projects that are not Search,
Ads, Chrome Apps, et cetera,
or the cream of the crop
revenue-wise thereof--
MELISSA BINDE: GCP.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: GCP--
forgive me, sorry.
GCP happened after my time.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, hello, everyone.
Most things that launch at
Google never get an SRE.
Most things that launch
at Google that do
get an SRE don't get--
an SRE team, mind you.
A two-continents, minimum of six
people on each team SRE team.
Some of them, it will
take quarters or years.
And so by the time SRE gets to
the regular, stable, on-call
vet, golly gosh, it's a really
well maintainable system.
Because the people
who are in charge
of adding features, and
potentially operational burden
to it, have had to deal with it.
So on the flip side--
I hate to use the word
leverage, because it
sounds like I'm spouting out
some "Harvard Business Review"
nonsense.
But the real leverage here
is if your ops team already
has 100% of the on-call,
where can they go from there?
And that may be what a lot
of people are thinking here.
Here's a real quick one.
Maybe not all new
launches abruptly,
but the mid-tier or
long-tail launches
don't have SREs on them.
And that's not meant
to be punitive.
That's meant to be,
we're focusing this--
again, at the risk
of mysticism or SRE
are this weird thing--
no, that's bad too.
SRE being attached
to a project being
there are, we're here to help.
This is a sign of focus.
This is a sign of
enthusiasm, of skill
above and beyond
that is necessary.
So you want to work with
SREs, as opposed to,
I want to add one more project.
What's one more
project, the Toad
says, as we add more
pagers to the ops team.
That's so incredibly different.
And you can iterate
towards that,
while maintaining that
leverage, respect, scarcity.
MELISSA BINDE: And if
you're thinking about that--
I did see enough nods that
I'm going to do this quick
follow-up--
realize that the deeper in
your stack something is,
paradoxically, the more
important is to have SRE on it.
Your leaf node, the stuff
that your customers actually
interact with, that's
probably pretty simple stuff.
And when it goes down, it
doesn't affect other things.
Your database, your Pub/Sub
services, your everything else
in that big
infrastructure layer,
that's where the danger is.
Because the blast radius
when those things go out,
and the complexity when those
things go out, is much higher.
So a good place
to start is where
if you have devs launching a new
service or a new feature that's
gaining adoption, that is
a good place to say, hey,
why don't you guys support
that until it gets big?
And we're happy to help you.
We're happy to figure
out how to improve
it, what monitoring you need.
But why don't you guys
handle it at the start?
MARILIA MELO: So we talked about
how the relationship of SREs
and devs are.
And we also started
talking about how
the relationship of SREs and the
business owners, or the product
team, because
they're the ones that
are actually going to decide
where the SREs are going.
Is that right?
ANDREW WIDDOWSON:
So the question
is towards how should SRE
relate with product deciders?
As opposed to maybe feature
engineering designers?
MARILIA MELO: How do the
relationship between the teams
that need SREs and how
do they request that
to the product team?
MELISSA BINDE: Yes.
So that is one of the
other things that we do.
Because as Andrew
said, we don't want
SREs to be-- so it turns
out, the way humans work
is that if I give you
something for free,
you do not care at all about it.
And if I charge you a penny, you
suddenly care way more than one
penny's worth.
And so we actually
treat SREs similarly.
When you're looking
at your headcount,
your headcount as
a VP is the sum
of the SREs on your product,
plus your engineers.
SREs come out of the same pool.
So if you're not willing
to staff SRE enough,
SRE will not take
on your service.
But when you do, that
counts against your product.
And that puts your
skin in the game.
You are literally
and deliberately
trading off engineers--
ANDREW WIDDOWSON:
Software engineers.
MELISSA BINDE: --software
engineers-- caught myself--
software engineers for
SREs very deliberately.
And while at Google we do report
through a separate management
chains that we have the ability
to escalate and to say no--
which we also
think is critical--
that's a very tight partnership.
And what part of your
question did I miss?
Maybe Andrew can
cover what I missed.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: I think the
mutual exclusivity of staffing.
What do you mean I'm melting
down a dev to get an SRE?
If only it was
fungible like that--
is actually really,
I think, important.
Other than that, really--
MELISSA BINDE: Oh, I
remember I wanted to say.
Sorry, Andrew.
SREs should be doing work that
SREs uniquely can do the best.
So if your SREs are
writing features
for your dev product,
that's not something SREs
can uniquely do the best.
The idea is that you're
staffing appropriately.
So your SRE team is the size
to get the most out of that.
And if you actually move
that back into the dev team,
you probably have to
put more people on it.
But simultaneously, if you put
too much headcount into the SRE
team, such that they're flowing
over and writing dev features,
they're going to be
less efficient in that,
because that's not their
specialization, that's
not their passion.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON:
Though that being said,
encouraging
cross-pollination rotations,
like being able to say I'm the
grand poobah of dollar sign
company, I hereby
pre-authorize that anyone with
a quarter's notice can spend
six months going to either team
from either team, in
order to build empathy--
shocking, right-- and breadth--
amazing.
MELISSA BINDE: We actually
financially incentivize
our devs to spend
six months with SRE.
And it's brilliant.
And an awfully large number
of them convert to SRE.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: More than 50%.
So it's billed as a catch
and release program.
But it's actually more
of a Hotel California.
They want to stay with
us, which is great.
MARILIA MELO: So
from all your talk,
it seems like SREs are
not only taking the pager
and looking at monitors.
It seems there is a lot of
culture related to that.
And then you have an interesting
title as SRE Culture Lead.
What does that mean?
What does an SRE
culture involve?
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: I don't
know what it means either.
But I'm about to find out.
No.
So I spent 12 years on-call
for all the different facets
of Google Search, which was
a fascinating and wild ride.
And then for the--
co-current with that--
for the last four years,
up until basically
a month ago, I
was also the co-founder and
a pretty significant designer
of a lot of the orientation
programs for all new SREs.
So I've done the hiring.
I've done the training.
I've done the
panicked one-on-ones
in the night, career
existential angst.
I've done it all with many
people in the SRE organization.
And I think SRE as a
concept, and Google SRE
as it is applied, has some
really fascinating things
to it.
I think there are things
we do really well.
But in our company, there
are 240-something SRE teams.
Divide by 2, because we're
paired over continents.
That's a lot of different
ways of rolling the dice
and trying out different ways of
doing things-- even just things
like weekly disaster
drills, or how
every single dev-SRE
partnership is designed.
I can give you an answer.
And it might be representative.
But chances are, there's
a lot of variance.
So I'm actually going around
and visiting teams one week
at a time to cross-pollinate
a lot of this stuff.
I think a lot of it is--
to me, to typify the
SRE personality--
I won't, because there are
multiple personalities--
but the set of personalities
is inquisitiveness, the ability
to circumvent hierarchy in
order to put the user first.
That sounds like a
lot of corp speak.
Let me try this again.
Realizing where the
rubber meets the road,
that you may be the most
decisive person in the room,
and then encouraging
people to take that on.
Case in point-- what I have
told every single new SRE that
has started at our company
is, when you are on call
and you get paged, you
are hereby officially
VP worth of authority for
your product in the moment.
Because, don't worry, it's
only several thousand dollars
a second.
We give you great
responsibility and trust.
SRE is a mesh, not
a tree, when it
comes to solving our systems,
because our systems are
distributed systems.
Our systems aren't
pointy-haired boss
under pointy-haired boss under
pointy-haired boss trees.
No offense.
So we need folks who
can think like a mesh.
It all comes into that.
And so I think our
culture is trust
each other, support each other.
It's not all hold hands and
kumbayah, but it's radial,
it's mesh.
It's not a tree, both
technologically and
people-wise.
MELISSA BINDE: I want to expand
on that just a little bit.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: Please.
MELISSA BINDE: Andrew,
as always, is spot on.
And I have little to say.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: Too kind.
MELISSA BINDE: When I was
considering coming to Google,
I had a friend who is the
director of all of our network
and traffic stuff, everything.
I was utterly
amazed that he went
on-call and utterly
terrified of the prospect.
And could not
believe it, thought
he was like god among men.
And I started at Google.
And I went through one of
the very early SRE edus,
which is where I met--
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: I'm
glad I didn't damage you.
Everything worked out great.
MELISSA BINDE: And I saw
the level of support,
the level of tooling,
the level of camaraderie,
and the level of
trust and acceptance.
And I told him I had no more
respect for him anymore,
because I saw how
much help he had.
But it actually took a lot
of the scary and the mystery
out of it.
And one of the things I value
most about SRE at Google--
because I work with
a lot of dev teams--
we are probably one of the
most diverse orgs I work with.
And I think that's
because to work here,
you have to be open to new
ideas-- to work in SRE,
you have to be
open to new ideas,
to different ways of thinking.
And you have to be able
to support each other
and work together.
Blameless postmortems
only work when
you can actually pull off
blameless with a straight face
and mean it.
And to have a culture to
enforce that kind of thing,
you really need to keep on
it and to not tolerate people
who are going to perturb that.
You need to be much more
careful caretakers of not hiring
jerks, of getting rid
of people who can't
work with people like them.
Because this is a high
stress role once in a while.
And then you're
not on-call again.
But every moment of
on-call could explode
into Google.com is down.
And no one wants to be the
reason that Search is down--
although Andrew, didn't
you take Search down once?
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: I did.
MELISSA BINDE: Yes, excellent.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: And my
team bought a bag of--
did you know, for
$100, you can get
a shredded, de-circulated
pile of $100,000 US
from the Treasury Department?
And my team once awarded me
with a bag of shredded money
with a Post-it Note on
it, with the location
of the cluster that I had
borked rather considerably.
And that was when I knew I
was one of the cool kids.
Because I wrote the postmortem.
We found out some really
interesting things
about the actions that I did
and the ramifications thereof
that we now use as part of our
proper reactive procedures.
I was like, maybe
this will work-- bam.
Oh, it made it worse.
But now we know, right?
And that would
never have happened
on many other types of dev and
IT ops type of relationships.
MELISSA BINDE: So think
about the type of environment
you need to build for
that to be actually
true to everyone's core.
That, to me, is
what SRE culture is.
And that's the only
way you can survive.
Because if you have hiding,
if you have finger pointing,
if you have jerks
on your team, that's
going to come out some
time and hit prod.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: Or
that you'll take it out
on your devs in the same way.
You'll just start projecting.
MARILIA MELO: So I have
only one more question
before we open the mic.
So please prepare
your questions.
And maybe it's a
challenging one--
but how do you define
success of an SRE team?
MELISSA BINDE: I had a
really good answer for this
like 44 minutes ago.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: Well,
I want to underscore
a point you made earlier
around, if you were
to release the headcount
behind the SRE team
back to the SWE team, that it
would-- the software engineer
team-- that it would take more.
There's a sense
of, we are working
on the most important things
at the hot, gooey center
of our product.
We are where the
rubber meets the road.
We are at the interface of
the system and the user.
How many people here have seen
"Tron," the original movie?
That's Tron.
They fight for the user.
SRE, Tron, very similar.
MELISSA BINDE: I am a manager.
So I have a little bit
more quantitative answer.
But you can pick
from between us.
For me it's that your SLOs--
if you don't know
what an SLO is,
please talk to
someone from CRE--
that your SLOs actually
are user-centric,
reflect the user experience,
not what you were
able to measure,
not what was easy, that your
team is spending at least half
the time doing enduring work.
That doesn't necessarily
mean writing code.
But it means you're
doing work that
is going to continue to
provide value at least
six months into the future.
That's my best definition
of engineering work
that I can come up with.
I think it's really critical
that you're not just patching
things and calling it code.
Look, it's not toil,
because I wrote code.
Well, if it's throw-away
work, it's still not enduring.
And that you have an appropriate
relationship with your dev
team.
It is possible to be too
chummy with your dev team.
I don't know if you guys
know the phrase "captured
regulators."
But I've seen SREs
who will bend over
backwards to justify
ignoring the fact
that they went out
of error budget,
because they've forgotten
that part of their job is--
I like to describe it as you are
the insurance policy that you
took out for yourself
for the future
when you were about to
make a bad decision.
And that's what things like
error budgets and SRE help for.
We say, hey, in the
calm times we all
agreed we would freeze
in this situation.
And now we really want
to get this release out.
We know the customers want it.
But we're out of error budget.
And, and, and, and--
well, what do the
customers think?
Do they actually value
this more than the risk
of additional outages?
And so it is very easy for
SREs to get caught up in that.
Because you want a good
relationship with the dev team.
But you also need a foot outside
the role at the same time.
And obviously, bad would
be being the other way.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: To this
point, another thought exercise.
I talked about scarcity.
To me, the successful
SRE team is the SRE team
that every dev team wishes
they could work with.
Not because it's,
here's a black hole
I can throw my
pagers into, hahaha.
Because in that
case, if you were
to say at your
company gathering,
raise your hand if
you want an SRE team.
And if everyone raises their
hand and snickers a little bit,
you know that's not good.
So here's an exercise.
Maybe this will work
for you, maybe it won't.
To your dev teams, ask
if you had an SRE team
that you were working with,
what would you work on together?
And if the answer is all
the bad stuff-- ehnn.
It's this interface to
apply for the honor of being
able to work with an SRE team.
It's the weirdest of things.
It's again to the consumer
electronics marketing technique
of $0.01 costs so
much more than $0.00.
But then also on the flip side,
right, take all of the answers
to this ingestion
survey and take it
to your fledgling new SRE team
and say, which of these answers
do you think is actually right?
And if the SRE
team then says, oh,
the ones that said we get
to work on tickets all day--
brrrn.
That's also bad, right?
It should probably be
somewhere in the middle.
Where if you as the arbiter of
who gets staffed to what says,
I can see that we want to reward
the right sets of matches,
where the SRE team says,
we want to extend and make
this product launch faster.
We want to stay up less
at night for all of us.
And if the dev team
says, we'd really
like to get some hard
critique of our systems
so that we don't launch
in a fiery ball of doom
later, all of that is good.
But you can imagine the cross
product of all of the bad.
Maybe try that out.
See what happens.
MELISSA BINDE: Can
I add one thing
that's not what you asked?
MARILIA MELO: Of course.
MELISSA BINDE: OK.
This is something I want to
make sure I say, just in case it
doesn't come up in a question.
I'm not a big fan of
methodologies that require
100% adherence to be true.
So any kind of purity
tests or whatever.
And I have heard, when talking
with people, sometimes people
see the SRE book as
essentially a purity test.
You have to do all of
these things in this
or you're not an SRE.
And I love the story
that I will tell,
that I usually don't
tell to anywhere
near this large an
audience, of an L6
engineer who showed up at stand
up one day, right after the SRE
book was released--
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: L6
meaning relatively senior.
MELISSA BINDE: I'm
sorry, staff engineer,
like one level above senior.
And he shows up with
the SRE book in hand.
And he says, hey, guys, I
read this really cool book
over the weekend.
Maybe we should do
some things in it.
Even at Google, every team
doesn't do everything.
And we do things different ways.
And we pick and we choose
what's important to us
and what's important
to our service.
The kind of one central
tenet that I see about SRE
is the understanding
of incentives
and the understanding of
the value of engineering.
If you're understanding how you
and your dev team have aligned
incentives and you're making
agreements ahead of time--
whatever those are--
and if you're making sure that
your team is doing engineering
work, all of the rest
are things that you
may use to get into that
place or to get better.
But please don't think
that if you're not
doing wheel of misfortune,
you're not doing SRE.
Actually, the CRE
folks would probably
tell you that error budgets and
SLOs have to be on that list.
Yeah, David's here.
Yeah, I'm getting
lots of nods from CRE.
All right, add that
to the third one.
Thank you, David.
But you don't have
to do everything.
You don't have to do
everything from the start.
And pick and choose what
works for you and your company
culture.
It's a cool area.
This is something unlike
anything else we do.
And it's an opportunity
for those of us
who love infrastructure and who
love the stuff around software,
to be able to have
this as a career.
And it's a very exciting time.
ANDREW WIDDOWSON: And the word
asymptotic really applies here.
You want to make
a large leap away
from a traditional or stale
or practice of 10 years ago
type situation of devs and ops.
You want to make a large stride,
a very strong foray into that.
And then ease off and
ease off and ease off
as you get closer to some
sort of theoretical limit.
Many companies I've
talked to have said,
well, we're going to
try one little thing
and see how that works.
I'm going to be the
only person here
who is going to tell you
that's not going to work.
Everyone else here is going to
be like, yeah, come talk to us
more about this.
The first hit is free.
If you say, we're going
to make this one little
incremental thing,
it's not going to work
and you're wasting your time.
So I'll be the bad cop here.
But now, for everyone
here who's nice
cop, and would love to
tell you more about how we
can work together to do this--
because I'm sure you
have lots of questions.
And we're going to answer a
lot of them up here on stage.
But for the extra
ones after this,
will you please raise
your hand if you're a CRE
or you're a dyed-in-the-wool
Google SRE here,
who would love to
answer questions,
look around and find the face of
the next person with their hand
raised.
[MUSIC PLAYING]